joining us now to discuss it is former
acting customs and border
protection commissioner mark morgan mark
thank you for taking time you just heard
lucas talking about a new tin facility
being put up in eagle pass
our viewers may recall in 2018 i
traveled 7
000 miles from san pedro sula honduras
all the way to piedras negras which is
immediately on the other side
of the border from eagle pass clearly
they know
a big surge is coming perhaps one we
haven't seen
the likes of yet yeah griff that's
absolutely right and there's so much to
unpack there
first let's talk about the the hypocrisy
with the facilities
now remember i was there in 14 and 15. i
was there under the trump administration
and look
the same facilities that now are being
built are being called humane and
necessary
are the same exact facilities that were
built under the trump administration
and the same exact facilities that were
utilized under obama and then vice
president bible administration
but depending if you're a republican
they are immoral humane
if you're democrat they're necessarily
effective and safe it's just political
hypocrisy
and look and people keep asking me
what's going to happen i keep telling
grip this is important the crisis is
already here
you just alluded to in january 78 000 a
month
in february it's going to be well over
uh uh 80 000. and right now they're
looking at 4 000 a day people
apprehend trying to illegally enter the
border the crisis is here it's because
of biden's open border policies
mark i want to drill immediately or more
specifically into the unaccompanied
children coming we could see as many as
9 000 in february
sources tell fox news so why
is it that these children are coming on
this dangerous trek
yeah and that's key griff and i
appreciate it it's a dangerous trick
and look it's a misnomer to say that oh
the reason why this has happened
is because of coveted national disaster
that is pure political spin
now we know worsening economic
conditions drugs drive
illegal immigration but if they know if
the message is clear they're not getting
in
those numbers will still come down these
numbers are crisis level numbers
we're looking again over 4 000 a day are
here for one reason and one reason only
the message is clear biden is rescinded
every effective policy to deal with
illegal migration
our borders are open that's what's
driving the numbers as you said
9 000 unincoming minors a single day 450
a day
that is a crisis it's already here so
what do they do mark how does this
administration tackle it and what are
you hearing
in terms of how they're going to respond
they they don't want to tackle it drift
that's what we're not talking about
this is what they want they we are now
seeing the united states governor we're
sheppard in a new era where they're
incentivizing encouraging facilitating
illegal illegal immigration and that's
what they want and now they're
scrambling around
doing everything they can to make sure
that they release people that have
entered illegally as fast as they can
and then they're making sure that ice
they're removing all
isis enforcement authorities to actually
remove them lawfully
when they're when they have order
removal this is the intent
this is what they want and it's
happening right now griff
and the threat that this poses is not
just isolated to our southern border is
that correct
that's right it's happening everywhere
obviously the majority of illegal
immigration on the southern border but
look and this is not just about
illegal immigration as well it's about
the resources that it takes to deal with
the illegal immigration we're already
getting reports now that
that the customs of border protection
are going to have to pull resources
off our critical national security
mission to deal now with the illegal
immigration numbers that the biden
administration has caused
it's circular it keeps going on this is
insanity
we've been down this road before this
administration knows it
and they're absolutely encouraging
facilitating the same thing that we saw
in 2019.
lastly in the time we've got remaining
you mentioned politics and i want to ask
you if the bite administration has
an intra-party problem alexandria
ocasio-cortez
tweeting about this week about that
saying this is not okay
never has been okay never will be okay
no matter the administration
or party talking about the new
facilities being opened what do you say
yeah what aoc says uh griff is of no
moment to me
she's the same individual that lied to
the american people that said border
patrol agents were forcing migrants to
drink from toilets
she lied she lied to the american people
we called her on it she continued to lie
so what she has and what she thinks is
no moment to me and is irrelevant
former cbp commissioner acting
commissioner mark morgan mark thanks for
taking time today we look forward to
fawn this story
it's certainly a growing one thank you
sir